from the Academy award-winning director
Steven Soderbergh mmm
soda burger comes a movie that proves
once and for all
when you look like Channing Tatum women
will literally pay you to hump their
faces Magic Mike Mead Magic Mike he may
not be a wizard but he is a hot dude
with all the right moves who struggles
to overcome social stigmas about his job
and can't seem to raise enough money to
start his dream business no matter how
hard he tries but that's okay because
he's grinding on stage next to the kid a
fresh-faced teen with a rocking body and
a drug problem that sends him into a
downward spiral alienating his best
friend his sister and landing him in
serious trouble with a violent drug
cartel but check out Tarzan the BP slab
of Man V who accidentally Rubies himself
jeez Louise
and as always there's Dallas the maestro
of man ass this old cowboy can still cut
a mean rug then cheat his longtime
business partner out of money abandoning
him as soon as it's convenient for his
own selfish interests but check out
those ABS whoa ride along on a thong to
Rich's journey based on the actual
career of a young Channing Tatum
that puts guys in the uncomfortable
position of wanting to trade lives with
a stripper and puts girls in the
uncomfortable position of wanting a man
who can barely finish a sentence think
of that that isn't [ __ ] I'm not my
magic and my Magic Mike right now
talking to you if you love strippers but
wish you could see all the mundane
details of their daily lives prepare to
watch a lot of that you
with too unsexy hours full of thong
purchasing crumpled bill straightening
loan applying okay we seem to have a
credit issue furniture evaluating is
this one of those retro like wait feel
there is russell read bookkeeping and
talking about the stock market teaching
about the stock market getting into some
Ameritrade like that i don't know why
more people don't do that you know just
from an investment standpoint woo get
swept away by the film's fantasy romance
that would have you believe
mike would ditch a life of casual
threesomes with olivia munn to pursue a
sourpuss who can't laugh like a human
being giving hope to women everywhere
that if she could lan channing tatum so
could i I mean so could you come on come
on come come on okay so get ready for
what's either a really dumb version of
Boogie Nights or a really smart version
of showgirls
that was way less fun than advertised
but there's no way we're gonna fall for
that again right ladies
okay that looks pretty damn odd whoa
shut up and take my money starring a
spuds x-bladz
biceps and beams finally 21 hump Street
oh come on there's no big stripping
finale I was waiting for one big hot
dance-off at the end make perfect sense
with a story right I mean I mean I'm not
gay me just admire the technique and the
athleticism you know the human Foreman
stuffs its art and stuff you know now
there's anything wrong with being gay I
mean one of my uncle's is gay it's cool
Love Wins be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers today we celebrate our
Independence Day if at first you don't
succeed
you're not as epic as I am I'm a sexy
wittle baby phenomenal cosmic power Oh a
little little both yesterday you said
tomorrow just do it